welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and we just got a new trailer for
james guns the suicide squad coming this
august
this looks like a red band trailer he
tweeted about this yesterday i'm like
james did you really have to do this on
the same day a falcon winter soldier
episode comes out great i guess i'm
shooting four videos today they're gonna
come out over the course of today and
tomorrow be patient but right now i'm
gonna react to this trailer uh
and i swear to god i have not seen this
yet you're seeing a raw uncut reaction
every reaction i've done is raw and
uncut or cut i don't know what uncut
is i don't do cocaine like tommy does he
doesn't do cocaine either he just it's
just a joke all right let's watch this
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business colonel these are
dangerous people
season two is clear to go fire uh three
two what are you guys doing what
you here to say to you you were gonna
save me it was a really good plan too
well i can go back inside and you can
still do it that's patronizing i'm so
sorry
harley quinn
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
can i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
[Laughter]
it's horribly beautiful we love it
yes that is your hand very good
we're going to die i hope so
here's the deal we fail a mission you
die we find out any information you give
us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you doctor no if you cough without
covering your mouth harley although that
isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
yeah what's the play how the hell must
listen up you're the leader you're
supposed to be decisive and i've decided
that you should eat a big bag of dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in mix if somebody said i'd eat
everything until the beach was clean for
liberty i would say no
problem why would someone put penises
all over the beach why mad men do what
they do
perfect songs
i'm going to get you out of here alive
oh that's them
[Laughter]
[Music]
for us
holy this looks so good uh i
remember the dc fandom behind the scenes
cut came out and i was like
there's a lot of interesting footage
here this looks so funny the camera work
is so exciting so yeah just reminder we
got idris elba as bloodsport he's the
guy who previously shot superman with
kryptonite bullet uh we got peacemaker
john cena who's
super funny right now he's gonna have
his own hbo max series that either comes
out at the end of this year or early
next year
no problemo would eat a beach covered
index
blueborg is playing javelin pete
davidson's playing blackguard michael
rooker's playing savant
nathan fillion is playing tdk which is
probably the detachable kid his like
limbs pop off david desmelchion is
playing polka dot man who just wants to
die
like oh god he probably hates his
existence daniella melchior is playing
rat catcher too steve ages playing king
shark who's basically a cookie monster
right nom nom
huh he's exactly what he wanted pete
capaldi is the thinker who's kind of
this release hand of elector figure
who's uh
they all eight mainly on he's playing
mongal alice braga is playing seoul
surya and then sean gunn james gunn's
brother is playing weasel and that's on
top of uh
joel kenneman coming back as rick flagg
uh jai courtney coming back as captain
boomerang viola davis coming back as
amanda waller and margot robbie coming
back as harley quinn
now how does this connect with the
broader dc eu uh
it sounds like according to zack snyder
his own snyder cut is not dceu cannon so
this is gonna be kind of a sequel
non-sequel to the first suicide squad of
2016. some of the characters are coming
back
will smith's deadshot's still around
jared leto joker's still around in this
universe but they aren't going to appear
in this movie probably it takes place
after the suicide squad but it's not
truly a sequel to it james gunn really
wanted it to be a sequel to the type of
missions of the john osterman suicide
squad comic series so this is just like
another mission they're going on and the
mission
is to liberate this south american
country from the grips of starro
we actually got an easter egg to starro
in the snyder kind of like a mechanized
star that's steppenwolf used
this is the gross organic hive mind
sorrow that attaches to one's face
the song choice of steely dan's dirty
work i
would never have imagined that james
gunn would pick this song but it is
perfect this is kind of like uh you know
the promise of the 2016 suicide squad
when that bohemian rhapsody trailer came
out were like this is gonna be really
fun
the problem with that though is that
trailer was produced by a separate
trailer editing house
not david ayers so there was like a
conflict between them of what type of
tone they were gonna have which is
what led to the mess of that movie
whereas james gunn tweeted he was
directly involved with the trailer
editors he
like went back and forth making a ton of
different versions deciding which
version of the trailer he wanted to show
this is from the beautiful horrifying
mind of james gunn this trailer and this
is the movie we're gonna get
look i don't have time to talk about
this more because there's a lot i gotta
make today but i will be doing a full
shot by shot breakdown of everything
that you missed in the trailer it's
gonna come out tomorrow follow me at ea
boss follow me rockstars and uh
i will see you next time bye
[Music]
you